What's up everyone?
I'm Andrea your
RealLife English fluency coach and
today we'll be learning English with the
biggest hits from Jennifer Lopez, also known as JLo.
Now before we get into
today's lesson I want to let you know
that every week here we make lessons
just like this one to help you learn
English without getting lost, without
missing the jokes and without subtitles
in fact Bangtan says that our channel is
an interesting way to learn English and
he has already learned new words.
So if that sounds good to you
don't forget to
hit that subscribe button and the bell down below so that you don't miss any of our new lessons.
Do you still struggle to understand fast
speaking natives?
Then why not check out
our Fluent with Friends course?
In this forty-eight week course
you will learn
with the first two seasons of Friends.
You'll receive PDF power lessons,
vocabulary memorization software, access
to our Fluency Circle global community
and so much more, and did you know that
you can try it right now for free with
our three part masterclass?
All you have to do is click up here or in the
description box below to learn more and
sign up now, we hope to see you there!
If you enjoy learning English with songs, well we
have many more lessons just like this one
with lots of different artists and songs,
so you can click up here or in the description box below to have a look and choose your next lesson.